un texto que sanciona las relaciones
sexuales extramaritales y la
cohabitación de parejas no casadas es la
nueva reforma al código penal en
Indonesia que Data de la época colonial
y que junto con la aprobación de la
mayoría de diputados ahora debe ser
firmada por el presidente
tras el largo debate Esperamos que la
gente entienda que hemos hecho todo lo
posible por acomodarnos a las
aspiraciones de los ciudadanos y hemos
debatido todas las cuestiones
importantes en las que nuestras
opiniones estaban divididas
Pero al final tenemos que tomar una
decisión la decisión histórica de dejar
este código que pertenece a los
neerlandeses las relaciones sexuales
fuera del matrimonio se castigarán con
un año de prisión y La cohabitación
ilegal con seis meses pero tales actos
solo pueden ser denunciados por el
cónyuge los padres o los hijos la
reforma también aumenta los castigos a
las mujeres que aborten sanción a los
insultos al presidente considera como
crimen la apostasía y expande las leyes
contra la blasfemia Defensores de
Derechos Humanos manifestaron frente al
parlamento denuncian una regresión en
las libertades civiles en el país
musulmán más poblado del mundo y que
durante mucho tiempo fue aclamado por su
tolerancia religiosa muchos también
argumentan que la ley se dirige
principalmente contra la comunidad
homosexual Ya que en el país el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
no está permitido